STEVE: A BRITISH DOCTOR WE’VE
BEEN TELLING YOU ABOUT HAS BEEN
PULLED FROM THE U.N. COMMISSION
INVESTIGATING THE ORIGINS OF
COVID.
WELL THERE’S NO OFFICIAL REASON
FOR HIS DEPARTURE.
DR. PETER DAZAK WAS A CRITIC OF
THE WUHAN LAB LEAK THEORY, SAID
NOTHING TO THAT, AND FACED
BACKLASH FOR HIS TIES TO THE
FACILITY HE HELPED GET THE  NIH
MONEY INTO WUHAN.
AINSLEY: GOP SENATOR MARCO RUBIO
IS PUSHING A BILL TO SANCTION
CHINA OVER THE COVID
INVESTIGATION, AND HE JOINS US
NOW.
GOOD MORNING TO YOU.
>> GOOD MORNING, GUYS.
AINSLEY: GOOD MORNING, SO
SENATOR, TELL US ABOUT THE COVID
ACT.
>> WELL WHAT IT IS 90 DAYS OF
THE BILL PASSING IF CHINA HASN’T
ALLOWED FOR A FULL CLEAR
TRANSPARENT INVESTIGATION AS TO
HOW THIS THING STARTED WE START
SANCTIONING THEM PEOPLE INVOLVED
IN SCIENCE, PEOPLE INVOLVED IN
THIS RESEARCH, THE INSTITUTIONS
INVOLVED IN THIS RESEARCH, WE
CUTOFF ANY AND ALL FEDERAL
FUNDING FOR ANY RESEARCH THAT
GAIN OF FUNCTION OR  ANYTHING
LIKE IT, IN CONJUNCTION WITH ANY
OF THESE AGENCIES OVER THERE.
LOOK, WE ALREADY KNOW ENOUGH
ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED IN CHINA.
I THINK, AS TO TELL YOU THEY’VE
DONE SOMETHING WRONG WHICH IS
THEY HAVEN’T ALLOWED THE WORLD
TO FULLY UNDERSTAND HOW THIS
THING BEGAN AND THEY’VE
COVERED IT UP.
NOW WHAT IT ACTUALLY LEADS TO
THAT’S WHAT THE WORLD NEEDS TO
KNOW BECAUSE THE NEXT ONE COULD
BE FAR WORSE THAN THIS.
CORONAVIRUS IS TERRIBLE.
COVID HAS BEEN TERRIBLE.
IT HAS KILLED PEOPLE, YOU’VE
SEEN WHAT ITS DONE TO OUR
SOCIETY AND COUNTRY AND THE
WORLD.
THE NEXT ONE COULD BE MUCH
DEADLIER AND DISRUPTIVE.
PEOPLE FORGET ALL THIS RESEARCH
THAT CHINA DOES IS STILL GOING
ON RIGHT NOW.
AS WE SPEAK, THEY ARE DOING IT,
TODAY.
IT DOESN’T STOP.
IT CONTINUES.
STEVE: IT DOES NOT, BUT DON’T
WORRY.
THE WHITE HOUSE IS ON THE CASE,
BECAUSE IF CHINA DOES NOT GO
ALONG WITH ANOTHER INVESTIGATION
AND BE MORE FORTHCOMING AND
START SPILLING SOME BEANS, THE
WHITE HOUSE IS GOING TO
INTERNATIONALLY ISOLATE THEM.
>> WELL, LOOK.
I MEAN, I THINK THERE’S A COUPLE
PROBLEMS THERE.
THE FIRST IS MOST OF THE
COUNTRIES AROUND THE WORLD
THINK THE WAY I DO LIKE I JUST
SAID.
STEVE: 100%.
>> IF YOU WENT AROUND AND ASKED
THEM THEY WOULD ALL SAY THE SAME
THING, THEY WON’T SAY IT
PUBLICLY BECAUSE ALL THESE
COUNTRIES CHINA HAS ENORMOUS
LEVERAGE AND THEY NEED CHINA
ECONOMICALLY, THEY ARE SMALLER
ECONOMIES AND SO FOURTH SO IT
TAKES A VERY FORCEFUL POSITION
ON THE PART OF THE UNITED STATES
FOR OTHER COUNTRIES TO BE
WILLING TO STEP FORWARD.
THERE ARE EXCEPTIONS, AUSTRALIA
BEING ONE OF THEM AND A FEW
OTHERS BUT GENERALLY SPEAKING
EUROPE, IT’S NOT THAT THESE
COUNTRIES AGREE WITH CHINA.
IT’S THAT THEY DON’T WANT TO
SPEAK UP BECAUSE THEY DON’T WANT
TO GET HIT WITH THEIR OWN
SANCTIONS AND HIT ECONOMICALLY
BUT THEY NEED FORCEFUL AMERICAN
LEADERSHIP IN ORDER TO MAKE
THESE THINGS HAPPEN.
I DON’T THINK YOU’VE SEEN
FORCEFUL AMERICAN LEADERSHIP ON
ANYTHING FROM THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION SO FAR MUCH LESS
THIS.
BRIAN:  LET ALONE IRAN WHAT THEY
ARE TRYING TO DO BEGGING TO GET
BACK INTO A DEAL WITH ONE OF
THE WORST COUNTRIES EVER
CONCEIVED, NOT THE PEOPLE BUT
THE GOVERNMENT.
SENATOR, I REMEMBER WHAT
CONGRESS DID AGAINST IRAN, WITH
SANCTIONS, THAT PUSHED THE
PRESIDENT TO TAKE ACTION.
YOU GOT THIS , COULD DO THAT
AGAIN.
I SENSED THAT IF YOU MADE THE
EFFORT AND I THINK YOU WILL,
YOU’LL GET A LOT OF DEMOCRATS ON
BOARD WITH THIS.
>> WE’RE HOPING TO.
HERE IS THE BOTTOM LINE.
ALL WE’RE ASKING FOR IS THAT
CHINA OPEN UP AND ALLOW A FULL
INVESTIGATION, BECAUSE THIS IS
NOT JUST ABOUT PUNISHING CHINA
WHAT HAPPENED IN THE PAST, OKAY?
THIS IS ABOUT PREVENTING IT FROM
HAPPENING AGAIN, FOR ALL WE KNOW
, AT THIS VERY MOMENT, THE
NEXT GREAT PANDEMIC IS BEING
DEVELOPED INSIDE OF A CHINESE
LABORATORY AND THEY ARE DOING IT
BECAUSE THEY WANT TO DEVELOP A
VACCINE OR  A CURE, BUT THE
THING INFECTS SOMEBODY THAT
WORKS IN THAT LAB AND THEY TAKE
IT OUT AND NOW THE WHOLE WORLD
GETS HIT.
I’LL REMIND EVERYBODY,
CORONAVIRUS IS BAD, THERE ARE
WORSE THINGS OUT THERE THAT
COULD LEAK OUT IF THAT’S THE WAY
THIS HAPPENS.
THE WORLD NEEDS TO KNOW BECAUSE
THIS IS NOT A CHINA ISSUE.
THIS IS A GLOBAL ISSUE.
BRIAN:  IF THEY DIDN’T LIE TO US
WE WOULD HAVE KNOWN WHAT WAS
GOING TO HIT US WE WOULD HAVE
HAD A TEST READY BUT THEY DID.
BRITISH SCIENTIST PETER DAZAK
HAS BEEN REMOVED
FROM THE COVID COMMISSION.
THIS GUY IS AN EMBARRASSMENT YOU
WATCH HIM ON 60 MINUTES LIE
THROUGH HIS TEETH SAYING I
BELIEVE THE CHINESE EVEN THOUGH
I DIDN’T SEE ANYTHING DIRECTLY.
EVERY TIME HE TALKS, THERE’S
SOME TYPE OF A AGENDA THERE AND
HE’S GOT DIRECT LINKS TO THE
WUHAN LAB.
NOW, HE ADMITS THERE MIGHT HAVE
BEEN BATS THERE WHEN HE SAID
THERE WERE NO BATS THERE.
THIS IS LONG OVERDUE.
>> YEAH, SOMETIMES THESE GUYS
LIKE TO PLAY GOD, AND SO WHAT
THEY DON’T, THEY WANT TO DO
THEIR RESEARCH BECAUSE THREE
KNOW WHAT’S GOOD FOR HUMANITY
AND THEY CONVINCE THEMSELVES OF
THE POSITION THEY ARE FROM AND
IN AND SO WHAT HAPPENS IS NOW
THEY ARE FEARFUL, OH, MY GOSH WE
DON’T WANT THIS THING LINKED
BACK TO THE KIND OF RESEARCH WE
DO, SO LET’S DO EVERYTHING
POSSIBLE TO SORT OF STEER PEOPLE
AWAY FROM IT AND COVER IT UP AND
THAT’S WHAT THIS GUY DID.
HE RALLIED A BUNCH OF SCIENTISTS
WHO DIDN’T DISCLOSE THEIR
CONFLICTS AND THEY HAD TO COME
BACK LATER AND FORCE MANY PEOPLE
TO DISCLOSE THEIR CONFLICTS
INCLUDING HIM.
STEVE: ONE OF THE THINGS YOU’RE
WORKING ON, YOU’RE ASKING THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES FOR A WAIVER, SO THAT A
FOOTBALL STAR AT THE NAVY, THE
ACADEMY, NAVY STAR CAMERON K
INLEY CAN PLAY FOR THE
BUCCS.
HE NEEDS A WAIVER AND BY THE WAY
THE FED IS GOING TO JOIN US IN
ABOUT 20 MINUTES OR  SO.
AINSLEY: BECAUSE JUST OF THE
MILITARY SERVICE.
STEVE: RIGHT EXACTLY, SO ANY
INCLINATION THAT JOE BIDEN WILL
SIGN THAT?
>> I DON’T KNOW YET.
THE WHITE HOUSE HAS BEEN NON-
COMMITTED SO WE DON’T KNOW
YET BUT HERE IS THE BOTTOM LINE.
PEOPLE GOT TO DO IT LAST YEAR.
THERE ARE PEOPLE PLAYING IN THE
NFL, MALCOLM PERRY THAT CAME
OUT OF THE NAVY PLAYS FOR THE
MIAMI DOLPHINS SO THIS
SOUNDS ARBITRARY WHERE LIKE
LAST YEAR, YOU GRADUATED LAST
YEAR THEY LET YOU DO IT IF YOU
GRADUATE THIS YEAR YOU’RE NOT.
HE’S NOT SAYING HE’S NOT GOING
TO DO HIS SERVICE.
I ALSO THINK THIS IS GOOD FOR
THE SERVICE ACADEMY.
THERE’S A LOT OF YOUNG MEN AND
WOMEN WHO HOPE THEY MIGHT HAVE A
CAREER IN ATHLETICS WHO SAY LOOK
IN THE OFF CHANCE THAT I GET
DRAFTED OR  I GET A CHANCE
TO PLAY PROFESSIONAL SPORTS, THE
REASON I DON’T WANT TO GO TO
THE ACADEMY IS I HAVE TO FORFEIT
THAT RIGHT NOW FOUR YEARS AHEAD
OF TIME SO I THINK THAT ALLOWING
THIS YOUNG MAN TO PLAY ISN’T
JUST FAIR, BECAUSE HE’S GOING TO
DO HIS SERVICE AND LIVE UP TO
HIS COMMITMENT BUT ALLOWING IT
IS NOT JUST FAIR BUT GOOD FORT
ACADEMY AND MAKE IT EASIER FOR
ME AND MY COLLEAGUES HERE,
TO FIND YOUNG MEN AND WOMEN TO
STEP FORWARD, AND BE WILLING TO
BE NOMINATED AND GO TO THE
SERVICE ACADEMIES.
AINSLEY: IT BE SO WONDERFUL IF
JOE BIDEN WOULD GIVE HIM THAT
OPPORTUNITY.
HE MIGHT NOT GET AN OPPORTUNITY
LIKE THIS AGAIN AND HE’S GOING
TO SERVE AND JOIN US LATER ON IN
THE SHOW.
THANKS FOR DOING THAT THAT’S
VERY NICE OF YOU.